and a lion is the exact opposite a lion
sits
rests it watches it observes it waits
for an opportunity and then when
opportunity comes like the you know the
gazelles running across the field
the lion looks up
sprints after the gazelle
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
okay we're here all right let me tell
you something
all right you ready yeah
i saw a great tweet that got me thinking
a lot and i've been reading a lot on
this topic so it's very a good
coincidence so it's this guy named dan
vasalo he said i'm convinced that
working 40 hours a week 50 weeks per
year for 30 to 40 straight years is
against our nature
yet the most skilled educated and highly
paid people i know tend to be unable to
consider any other path that doesn't
involve enduring this artificial
lifestyle
do you sean agree or disagree
uh well
actually let me phrase it differently do
you do you think that that 40 hours 50
hours a week for 50 years is outlandish
like where do you fall on that
i totally agree with this i think that
the work week concept is
um
sub-optimal
somewhere between bogus and sub-optimal
all right so
why do i think that
so first there's like this uh assumption
that's like
we have linear output that uh you come
in eight hours a day all eight hours are
going to be roughly equal nobody says
this but it's just implied in the way
that we work um you're expected to sort
of be there for these hours and then on
top of that there's like well cool then
monday through friday should be the same
and then you're working 50 out 50 weeks
out of the year that should be they
should all be roughly equal like we know
anybody who does
non like factory work non-like
industrial work
if you're working with your brain
uh you're doing knowledge work
that work week doesn't make any sense
and i think you were you kind of like
nerd out about the history of like the
history of things the history of the
work week the history of you know the
industrial revolution and [__] like that
and
it seems to me and maybe i could be
wrong here but it seems to me like this
idea of the way we work where you go to
a central place and then you work eight
hour shifts and you do that five days
out of the week and then you do that 50
weeks out of the year and you do that
for 30 years out of your career
that is like the industrial age and it
makes sense if you're actually working
in a factory because
you can sort of uh
pick pack you know you can sort of like
do all the these like
these physical tasks with a certain set
of output
and uh it can be measured and like just
the more hours you're there the more
output you're gonna get whereas
if you're a programmer or you're a
designer or you're a
you know a product person or you're a
marketer
you might have one hour where you just
get this burst of creativity of insight
and that hour was like the whole day's
work and it might take you a whole day
to get to that point but that hour was
like the most valuable bit so i think
that the way people work today
is we still work the schedule of a
factory but we don't work in factories
anymore for the most part so yeah i
totally disagree with i totally agree
with the tweet which disagrees with the
work week
so i'm reading a few things the first
thing that i that i've read recently is
this great book called the science of
fear
and in it he talks about the history of
humans a little bit and how
we look at fear and what we're afraid of
isn't always logical for example when
september 11th happened in 2001 in the
year 2002
flights went down as uh
sorry i should rephrase that actually
the less people traveled on an airplane
right because they were fearful they
were afraid to fly
yet
car wrecks that next year 2002 went up
significantly so much so that had there
been a terrorist attack and a plane went
down every single week
uh for a whole year
it actually would have been safer than
driving
and we are incredibly fearful and that's
just one example another example
i'm paraphrasing here i'm going to get
some numbers wrong how many people do
you think die a year from shark bites
probably tiny right uh i don't know
let's call it die every year i think
it's like
sub 1 000 that's my guess
so since the history of us recording
this the stat which i believe was like
1880 or something like that
it's around 200 people ever
so a minuscule lifetime like lifetime
it's so sharp bites happen each year but
something like one to four every year
are
you you die and yet we're incredibly
fearful of that and
and the reason i'm bringing this topic
up is when i was reading this book he
has this great line and again i'm
paraphrasing but he says something like
if you look back uh of like the homo
sapiens so like the the kind of modern
human and if that if it's a history book
of what that is of the life of that of
the history of the homo sapien that book
will be like 500 pages and of the hunter
gatherer stage that will be something
like a paragraph and this since the uh
industrial age should you know whatever
we just call modern so let's just say
like the last thousand years or so
that's gonna be like one or two or three
sentences a paragraph let's say
sort of put and and the reason why this
is important is the way that our our
emotions the way that we live our life
it
we look at like well you know for the
last hundred years we've been doing this
it's like well actually for the last
tens of thousands the last millions of
years whatever we've done something else
and to to bridge that to this other book
sapiens have you read sapiens
no but i feel like i have because
everybody references everyone so i
almost feel like i know it but go ahead
yeah it's like the tech bro tech bro
book so i'm paraphrasing again we should
explain it's the tech bro book because
it's like it's the book that's not about
tech that all the tech bros like because
it makes you look like you're more
worldly because you know about humanity
and like you know oh yeah it's not just
about tech
so it's not all about it so before you
know cities emerge
and things like um uh you know
capitalism as we know it kind of came
into play um a lot of times
like hunter-gatherers and then when the
agricultural revolution came about we
were working like something like 20
hours a week so we would work to get our
food we would work to um take care of
our family a little bit but it was a lot
of leisure time and i find it to be kind
of interesting that when i look at like
guys like an elon musk but for the
record i agree with what that per that
tweet said but i do agree that if you
are going to build like these outlandish
things like an elon musk type of thing
it does give you a competitive advantage
to work
really really really hard and regardless
if you start anything you got to work
really hard but i don't think that you
need to do that for that actually that
long and i would actually say i this is
a guess i i don't have insight
there's a world where you could be an
elon musk and actually work 40 hours a
week right now but
um i was thinking i've been thinking a
lot and i'm gonna come a little bit more
prepared next time but the history of
the work week and i do think it's crazy
to dedicate 60 70 hours a week or
whatever it is to work that's considered
like hard work for like 40 years 20
years i think that's wild i think it's
crazy let me give you my uh
my a couple of frameworks that i picked
up along the way first one from tim
ferriss so here we go read four hour
work week
and everybody who reads the four hour
work week gets what i call the four hour
fever which is right after you finish
the book actually even even before you
finish the book when you're about
halfway through
you're it's like you're in a fever dream
you're reassessing every part of your
life you're like oh
yes i've seen the light i need to be
doing things this way
now when i'm i can't i can't see the
world the same way again which is why
it's such a great book and why it got so
so popular was because it had that sort
of red pill moment where where you
couldn't really go back to living in the
same sort of fog you were living in
before
and the thing about the four hour work
week one thing he says is
he points out that you know true wealth
is has not has very little to do with
money money is an accounting scheme that
we use to keep track of wealth and um
and you know true wealth comes it comes
into play of like you have to take into
account other factors so who is
wealthier
a person in new york city making 500 000
a year or a person in bali making 150
000 a year
well the person in new york by
traditional measures would be doing you
know four times better
but um but of course you know if you if
you go live that life that's not the
case right because in new york you have
to pay your cost of living is three or
four x your schools you have to pay for
private schools or whatever um basically
your your effective uh your effective
wealth which is basically a combination
of how much free time you have and how
much like buying power you have
um is lower than the person in bali
who's working you know half the time
making four times less but also living
in a place where the cost of living is
ten times less or whatever it is
and so he called that the new rich tim
ferriss called this the new rich he
basically is like the new rich are
people who have time
and the new rich are people who
um you know they can they're they don't
they're not tied to any location they're
not tied to any schedule
and um they have they're working in a
way where they're earning just enough to
hit their target and their target is
some amount of money that covers your
life life costs and so they um where
basically you're
you have a freedom number that you come
up with where it's like okay once i'm
earning this much and then the the
effective kind of like compounding of
interest that i make off that money is
going to cover my life burn then i'm
financially free
and he talked about how like the way
that people work today which is like you
work your ass off for
you know from age 20 to 65 right so for
this like 45 year period
you work like crazy you sacrifice time
you sacrifice travel you sacrifice
health because you're working so hard
and then basically once you turn 65 all
of a sudden okay now it's time to retire
and go do all the fun things go travel
now as a 65 year old and he points out
like
it's way more fun to travel like
now than it is when you're 65 right like
it's more fun to do things in your 20s
and your 30s and not put off the fun
until you're 65
and also
um you know why do we do this where we
basically trade the first half of our
life
you know trading you know time for money
and then the second half of our life
trying to give back money to get our
time back
and uh that doesn't really make too much
sense so once i first heard that i
thought about oh yeah there is this
lifestyle
where you can be remote
right like you're in i don't know where
you're in brooklyn right now something
like that you're in new york manhattan
you're in manhattan now uh it doesn't
matter where you are you can do your job
and so you have more freedom than the
average person it also is that you can
work three hours a day instead of eight
hours a day all that matters is what you
get done so it's not like a factory we
have to come in to work so i think this
is the new rich and the last part of the
new rich that he talks about is mini
vacation many retirements so instead of
having one big fat retirement when
you're 65 how do you have like little
one you know six month one year 18-month
sabbaticals that you take in your 20s
your 30s your 40s your 50s rather than
just putting it all off till the very
end so what do you think about that
lifestyle first
so that lifestyle is great and it's not
actually anything new um and but we
don't really assume that it's new so i
was out i was at dinner with this i
think did i tell you about this uh the
guy who had a company in china
yes you did so basically as a recap
there was a guy who i went with out to
dinner with and he had 5 000 ish
employees in china and there was this
debate at the dinner table of how
china's gonna kick america's ass
and this guy this isn't me saying this
so don't get me flak this guy was saying
i think that that's totally false a lot
of americans think that but the truth is
is that americans probably work harder
um you know we actually work really
really hard americans do you know it's
it's
at our company we would give three weeks
uh time off most people did not take
that entire three week time off um most
people would take like 10 days
and that was just like that's just my
little uh example but
i actually think that americans work
incredibly hard compared to our peers
throughout the world maybe not the
hardest but top tier
but in a lot of the guys who i like to
read about so for example joseph
kennedy's an example
prior to him even making all of his
wealth joe kennedy was jfk's father he
um was worth he was like the 10th
richest person in america at the time so
he was incredibly wealthy
and what he would do even prior to that
is he would work really hard for nine
months and then chill for three months
uh in palm beach in florida and this he
wasn't incredibly wealthy when he did it
and this is actually incredibly common
so you'd read about andrew carnegie
taking a trip to europe now when you
take a trip to europe without a plane
that's a six-month thing
and so
that i this this idea of taking time off
it's not like i mean i'm exciting so i
don't think it's new but i don't think
it's common either right so there's
something i don't think it's combination
and it's not common now and that's why
it's i think interesting now and from my
point of view by the way i think so i
lived in china for two years i lived in
indonesia for a year i lived in a bunch
of different places that are like kind
of like more
third worldly and considered to be like
like right now i would say the popular
popular uh opinion
uh amongst like you know our peers is
that china and china people work a lot
harder and they're more like sort of
like they're advancing faster they're
you know us is all tangled up in its own
mess and this is also the soft
generation and everybody gets a trophy
there's all these complaints about the
us
and uh i hope what your friend is saying
is true um that america's not america
does work hard and is not going to be
not going to get its ass kicked by china
but i don't know what i saw when i lived
there was
the average person there works far
harder and is much tougher and the like
the expectations of your rights and your
leisure
um and your like the coddledness of
employees is like
night and day like uh the average
employee here lives like a king compared
to the average employee in china or
indonesia from what i saw which was two
things there were a lot of people in
china they live in the rural areas and
then they come work in cities because
that's what jobs are and so extremely
common practices you literally leave
your family you have a kid you leave
your family you go work in the city your
gran you're a parent so the grandparent
raises the kid
you send money back every week
you live in the city you don't see your
family and then you go travel on
occasional holidays or weekends
back to the countryside to see your
family like in the u.s
that would be considered sort of like
you know slave labor almost like that's
not a common pattern in indonesia and
china that was such a common pattern
amongst the kind of like blue collar
class and then in the white collar class
they had this sort of like
i forgot what they call it 996 it's like
9 a.m to 9 00 p.m six days a week
um
you know like
i worked at a tech company the average
engineer came in at probably 10 a.m
uh you know took a nice hour for lunch
uh you know two hours later at noon
and then you know by five they were
going to their you know going to the gym
or going wherever they were gonna go and
they were gone and uh oh by the way in
between you know they got to sit with
their triple monitor set up with their
bose headphones provided by the office
eating you know having cheetos fed to
them so it's like i do think that the
american worker from what i've seen is a
lot more coddled but what i would say is
that
the average american has a much higher
career focus than the average person in
other countries i lived in in australia
i lived there and this quality of life
was high and people might have worked
about the same hours as the us a little
bit less but it just wasn't as big of a
part of their life was their career in
the us i feel like career is like such a
big thing in people's lives work is such
a big part of your life it's such a big
part of your identity your value in
society your value as a dating partner
you like care about you're always trying
to like move up and in australia people
were just way more chill about it and i
felt the same in indonesia and in china
so even though somebody might work
14 15 hours a day in pretty harsh
conditions
they weren't like striving to like climb
the ladder and that like climbing the
ladder is a big thing in the u.s i
didn't see that in china even for people
that worked harder
now i think though to wrap up this part
when we talk about work we're talking
about basically
um
for most the listeners we're talking
about people who sit at a computer for
eight hours a day and that's what we're
defining as work
now i'm not saying but when i say so
we're defining work as like doing
something you don't necessarily want to
do in exchange for money
now i actually think that you should
work incredibly hard if i define work as
like you should work out super hard you
should like run errands you know you
should like handle family business you
should also it's hard
yeah well yeah you know you got to like
i i think that you should have like i i
believe a lot of times you should have
like structure around what you're doing
and you should put a lot of effort and
live you should live hard kind of as is
the way that i think about it you should
do things like with intention but i
don't i think that working 50 hours a
week for 30 whatever years when i think
about it now i'm like that is crazy if
you only live once um and i'm starting
to read this book
um i just ordered it i don't remember
the name but uh it's about a guy who
goes and interviews elderly people
people in the and people in the hospice
who are about to die
and they talk about what they regret and
things like that and uh
just reading the reviews of it has like
already changed my perspective slightly
that's that's cool i like that uh naval
has a great one where he basically talks
about this like idea of
you know most people work like cows when
we should really work like lions so i
don't know if you've heard this
framework but it's a good one which is
a cow if you watch a cow all day a cow
just stands in the grass slowly wagging
its tail just
eating grazing on the grass
neck down
slowly munching on grass which is kind
of like not the highest sort of like
you know like it's not the most dense
nutritious you know food and the cow
just sits there does that it has four
stomachs to just sit there and digest
grass
and so cows graze all day 10 hours a day
and uh and a lion is the exact opposite
a lion sits
rests it watches it observes it waits
for an opportunity and then when
opportunity comes like the gazelles
running across the field
the lion looks up
sprints after the gazelle like not not
walking not not jogging sprints
catches the gazelle
feasts on the gazelle which is like more
dense nutrient more more value there
then
celebrate relax
rest and get ready for the next sprint
and basically neval's point is work like
a lion like if you're if you're a
creative person or you want to be sort
of wealthy which is freedom and time
working on stuff you love and creating a
lot of value in the world um work like a
lion not like a cow but if you look at
the way the work week is scheduled it's
a cow it's a cow's work week the cows
work week is
go sit on this chair neck down monday
through friday eight hours a day
leave for the weekend come back do it
again do that 50 times in a row that's
the year
you know congratulations and if you have
a bad week that's that's a negative we
don't count the number of amazing weeks
we just count the number of not bad
weeks
and um and so people work like cows and
so i think that that's a very useful
frame of reference is to say okay
because because a lot of people who are
high achievers they're down to sprint
what they're not down to do is
feast
celebrate relax rest and wait for the
next big opportunity because they have
nervous energy they're always just
trying to do some do more do more more
more and when you do more more more you
actually are working like a cow not like
a lion
can we talk about naval so
do i want to hear do you have any intel
or insights on him that
first of all let's explain who this guy
is but i would like to hear some stories
about him because i just read his uh
listened to his book what was it called
the naval's almanac the valmanak yeah
it was awesome
but i've never met the guy i don't
really know that many people that know
him really have do you have any insights
on i don't know i i don't i never met
him uh i've chatted with him once or
twice just briefly very very very very
briefly like a twitter dm
and once on a clubhouse so so
for all intents and purposes i don't i
don't know the guy he doesn't know put
it better he doesn't know me
i feel like i know him pretty well he
doesn't know me okay
um but i do know some people who know
him i've asked him to tell the
background tell the background of who
this guy is
uh basically i i'll go back a little bit
further so so he uh immigrated he's a
he's an indian guy he grows up in in
somewhere in new york uh
not wealthy i think single mother
um
you know wasn't really like you know him
and his brother there wasn't really like
a sort of glamorous lifestyle whatever
growing up uh grows up thinks he wants
to be a scientist sort of decides okay
actually i'm more interested in the
business side of things or i have more
of a knack for business
and ends up early on in the dot com boom
creates a site called epinions which is
like a website for i think it was
reviews and opinions on on products i
believe it was sort of like yelpish um
but more for i think products than for
for
you know locations so crazy opinions
opinions actually works but some [__]
goes down i don't know the full
backstory but like you know the the
important parts is opinions kind of kind
of was working and then you know it's
still it's not around today so it didn't
fully work but
uh he got kind of screwed by his vcs so
he gets screwed by his vcs gets screwed
out of what he was owed uh you know that
puts a ship chip on his shoulder
basically i think what happened is that
he left the company or disagreed with
his co-founder the vcs took the side of
his co-founder
and they bought back some of his shares
or they told them they were worthless so
we sold them for very little but then
eventually i believe they either went
public or they were bought by a company
that goes public and it becomes a
financial success for a little while at
least right
and he didn't get what he didn't get the
win that he would have otherwise been
owed out of that he felt like he was
screwed over by his vcs and then he said
well why was i screwed you know i think
the good partiers took some
accountability for it said okay they may
have acted poorly but i put myself in a
position where they could act poorly
where they could legally act poorly
towards me and so he that that got him
very interested in this idea of term
sheets and contracts and the the deal
documents that go into when an investor
invest in a company cause he was the
founder and as most founders like
investor wants you okay great they know
they do this this is their day job is
doing deals investing in companies they
hand you a piece of paper that says hey
and they tell you oh it's all standard
and you say okay [__] if it's standard
it's standard i don't know this some of
this stuff looks kind of scary but like
i don't know i don't know how to push
back i don't know if they say this is
standard okay whatever you sign the
document and uh you don't really fully
understand until you know uh until
things go sideways and as they say with
all deals you know deals are written you
know contracts are written for the worst
case scenario not the best case scenario
and uh and the worst case scenario is
like you know you found a breakup or or
whatever you get kicked out of the
company what are you owed and so he
creates venture hacks venture hacks is
basically a
you know sort of like demystified
version of term sheets so he basically
starts writing down hey founders here's
what you need to know about raising
money here's how the process
here's what the yeah here's what the
terms are you should know here's the
[__] up terms you should avoid here's
the good vcs you know that sort of thing
so you just put out a blog with no clear
like it's not like a business he started
necessarily but he puts out a blog i
think it became a book at some point
and he keeps investing in the kind of
like he's in the game still he's playing
he's playing the startup game still
next thing he does is he creates angel
list which starts off as very simple oh
hey founders i helped you figure out
the dynamics of raising money the deal
terms but that doesn't actually help you
go get investors so why don't we do this
i know 100 angel investors if you want
to raise money this is a list of angels
angel list uh here's a list of angel
investors and i'll just send out three
or four good startups every week to this
list and then that'll help you get
funded and so it starts off as an email
first product ends up becoming full like
platform and network basically linkedin
for the startup community
and now it's a multi-billion dollar two
or three billion dollar at least company
that is you know the best place to go
you know list your startup get raise
money if you're an investor that's like
i use it for my rolling fund so i use it
as the back office to launch a fund
if you're an engineer you can use it to
go get a job it's like all all the
all the um
different transactions that need to
happen in the startup world whether it's
hiring whether it's raising money or
it's it's
investing money angelus does it so
that's the that's the long story short
on him along the way invests as an angel
investor in twitter in uber in postmates
does extremely well as an angel investor
uh during that time probably a
billionaire at this point yeah
i don't think a billionaire i would i
would say no but uh but you know stupid
money for sure right like uh uh you know
hundreds of millionaire for sure and i
think the reason why a lot of people
like him there's a lot of guys in
silicon valley that have that story
right i created a company
it sounds it's definitely exceptional to
create a billion dollar company or to
angel invest in uber and twitter and
postmates and multiple
billion dollar companies at the earliest
rounds that's clearly impressive but
naval stands apart not for that he
stands apart because he has
an extreme
uh
clarity of thought and wisdom that he
shares on both twitter his podcast this
is the naval podcast
and uh and he's kind of like a
philosopher about both life as well as
business and
and that's why he's built this cult
following and when he started this
philosophy
schtick um he got mocked so basically
naval builds angelus it starts becoming
quite successful it actually took a
while i think now it's going to be just
the biggest thing ever i mean when i see
how it works now i'm a customer it's
going to be huge
and
he starts this twitter stick where he
tweets one line tweets that at the time
was not very popular now everyone does
it but it's like he'll just do a one
sentence tweet we call them fortune
cookie tweets yes and
you know they're silly but like they're
useful and people would kind of mock him
at first now he went on joe rogan and
people start looking at him as this like
tony robbins s like guru and he blows up
and regardless
i think it's the other way around i
think he got on joe rogan because people
already started to feel that way about
him that's what i mean
the stuff you put out one thread
particularly that that just went nuts
which was called how to get rich without
getting lucky if you're gonna go read
one twitter thread today go go read that
one um
and that was a bit more i mean that's
that's like original wisdom or you know
there's original content
the internet already lacks original
content forget original content original
wisdom is very hard to come by anytime i
think i think of something wise i'll
tweet it out and then somebody will say
yeah you know that's what uh you know
that's what yogi berra said back in 1940
or something like that i'm like
okay great i wasn't trying to rip him
off like i this is a independent
realization i've had by making mistakes
in my life um but it's i found it so
hard to really have original wisdom he
genuinely has original wisdom and of
course many things he says are packaged
and repackaged from philosophers that he
follows and
stuff he tried but
uh at the end of the day you know he's
putting together sort of like an
original
uh set of philosophy a set of ideas that
come together as a philosophy
and he has this fund now that you can
join but in order to join it so he
charges crazy fees
um
uh you can go on
more
i think more
if you go to uh he's got it's a
syndicate and a rolling fund and you
could actually see what they are you
could read them but they're
significantly higher than normal and he
recently had a
meeting
for his syndicate members i had a friend
who went and he said something like i'm
no longer going to do b2b software
because even though it's like a surefire
way to make money it's just boring to me
and now i'm only going to invest in
things like space and things that are
these moonshot crazy ideas what do you
see where these are
uh i'm looking now i don't see the fees
i think maybe i have to like find the
docs but i'd be surprised if it was that
crazy i think i would bet he takes a
higher carry than fee but that's what it
is all right sorry when i say fee uh i
wasn't
meaning management fee so let me tell
you two things
uh one is have you heard his theory on
the like kind of back to the work week
thing like let's connect these two ideas
so he's got this theory on like the
future of work have you have you heard
what he says about this no
so basically he says like okay um
two things he's like one the size of the
firm is shrinking
so we've seen like you know companies
the big companies today are all like
tens of thousands of employees and then
you start to see like these outliers
where it's like oh instagram when it
sold for a billion dollars was at 13
people right like that was kind of
amazing for 13 people and really they
hired five of them like in the last few
months so it really was like eight
people created a billion dollar company
and there was a prediction that like
soon if not already a one-person company
will create a billion dollar uh one
person can create a billion dollars of
enterprise value and we're all kind of
like looking around waiting for that
exact scenario um and i think bitcoin is
one of the closest where satoshi
basically created a
multi-hundred billion dollar thing and
it's like not only one person
well it's most likely one person but we
don't even know who the person is kind
of amazing no company there's no no ceo
no no chief marketing officer whatever
so he started observing that like the
size of the firm is shrinking in general
and that people work their best in these
like small rag tag
um and so what he what he thinks is the
future is what i'll call like the
ocean's 11
way of working so ocean's 11 what is it
one person george clooney identifies
we're robbing this bank right we're
robbing this casino this is this is the
next target
uh what person one basically sends out
the bat signal they text out the trusted
group people who all have a unique set
of skills and says hey we have our next
target they say cool they read the brief
the brief basically says here's this
casino it has all this money uh they
have these jewels we're gonna go rob the
bank here's how we're gonna do it and
you're gonna you're gonna be hey you
know like asian gymnast guy you're gonna
be responsible for going through the
laser wires and hey pickpocket guy matt
damon you're going to go pickpocket the
the the
the
boss you know and get the key and
basically this is how work is going to
work so what he thinks is going to
happen is
you're going to have
either independent or small teams of
people let's say you and let's say the
four key people who built the hustle
that you could basically get a text
message on your phone that gives you the
next
mission and either you or as the leader
are coming up with that mission or
somebody else puts out the mission out
to the universe says hey we want
somebody to build
you know the hustle for bitcoin right
and you could basically say boom accept
i accept the job
and then that fans out to the four
people you trust you guys get together
and you do this sprint for like nine
weeks building the foundation there
you collect your jackpot of money you
split the you split the winnings you get
the most and then you know steph gets
the next most and trung gets the next
most or whatever and then uh and then
you all go your way again until the next
mission hits and he basically feels that
this is how things are going to work
more like you know mission impossible or
ocean's 11 field agents that basically
take missions when they want the mission
has a set bounty the bounty gets you
know you get completed you get you rate
and review each other right i review the
task giver the brief giver they review
me as the as the agent and then we go on
our way and we see this with like uber
drivers today but it hasn't shifted into
like creative knowledge work but that's
his that's i'm paraphrasing or i'm kind
of extrapolating for what he said but
i think that's what he thinks the future
looks like what do you think of that
i think that that applies to a lot of
things but not everything i think that
for the people listening to those
podcasts it will apply to a lot of their
work but at the end of the day i need
someone to come pick up my trash every
single day or every once a week you know
what i mean i need some type of
consistency and i think that naval and
well the robots will be doing that
maybe but sometimes already in my street
dude
the driver there is a driver in the
thing but the guy drives up to the house
this huge claw arm comes grabs my trash
can like it's a toy and in one of those
claw games at the thing dumps the trash
on into the thing puts it back down and
he just keeps driving guy doesn't get
out soon that guy's not gonna need to be
there it's just gonna be computer
driving that that whole thing so there's
this fruit stand on the corner of where
i'm staying right now and it's two guys
who run it they work 12 out they it's 12
hours so one one person does the one 12
hours the next and it's open 24 hours a
day seven days a week
it's crazy and so you can go and buy a
pair at 3am on this corner it's wild and
i think a lot of new york is like that
you know in san francisco everything
closes at like one it never sleeps yeah
yeah yeah and i think that for a lot of
uh stuff that unfortunately is going to
be necessary although i don't know if
it's necessary but people are going to
continue doing it that way but what
you're talking about for intellectual
work or for work that requires um you
know coding or blogging or something
where you can build it once and sell
many times i think that is a great way
to do it not only do i think it's a
great way and effective way to do it i
think it's significantly more fun well
i've had this realization which is
um
like okay my grandfather my grandfather
worked essentially i think he worked in
like an explosive factory basically like
a bomb factory
and so you know hey animation guys start
here okay grandfather works in a in a
explosion explosives factor bomb factory
and he goes to work he basically wears a
hard hat he wears his glasses his
goggles and um and he's operating like
machinery heavy machinery that's like
his day-to-day
then his son which is only like you know
30 years younger than him does a job
that to my grandfather would seem like
what do you mean this is work where's
your where's your hard hat where's the
factory where's the danger where's the
what you're not standing 12 hours a day
if you're 14 hours a day on the line
like what are you doing because my dad
carried a briefcase into an office went
to a cubicle sat down at a desktop
computer and essentially wrote roughly
like you know emails memos and then you
know flew on a plane to go meet a
customer shook their hand cut a deal
signed a piece of paper and then carried
that piece of paper back with them
and then my dad looks at me and he's
like
you call this work what are you doing
here like you know this is now again 30
years later and work is now again an
unrecognizable shift he looks at me and
he says you just sit in front of your
laptop on your couch or you'll go you'll
go travel it doesn't matter you can just
sit with your little phone and do your
whole job and so i you know i sit with
my laptop basically and i just talk to
other people through video chat i don't
even need to get on a phone or i'll
create content you know as my thing or
i'm a programmer
and
then if i think about my daughter right
my daughter blush she's two years old
right now
when she works i'm sure it's going to
look like something completely
unrecognizable and basically looks like
leisure to her like to from my point of
view because i'm like dude back in my
day i had to sit at my laptop and type
type type type and she's going to be
like oh yeah we just use our voice
assistants and i'm just like i have a
drone that follows me around and it's
creating content for my channel and i
have a thousand subscribers and that's
my payment that's my income is my
thousand subscribers watching me on my
drone vlog or whatever the hell like the
future is going to look like it's hard
to predict my grandfather never could
have predicted that his son would do
what he does my dad would have never
thought that i do what i do that means
i'm unlikely to be able to predict what
my kids are going to do 30 years from
now that gets me both excited but also
makes me think oh i need to plan for
something a little more radical than
what just feels like
a bit further progression from where we
are today
so i'll give you this is a little
tangent but uh and robert robert green's
uh is one of my favorite authors and
he's a historian a little bit and he
wrote about how you know how this idea
of like how our parents always complain
about young people they don't understand
this or that hard work yeah yeah and
we'll say the same thing about people
younger than us so some of the earliest
writings that we've discovered of
language of the written language not
just pictures but uh words uh on walls
or whatever
it was people complaining about how the
kids don't i swear to god this is what
he was like this wonderful example he's
like in fact this is like so common that
some of the earliest works we've ever
been able to read it's about complaining
about how they're nervous about the
future because the young people don't
understand something dude that's so
funny uh first of all
first of all someone's lying because
i've heard the bitcoin people are all
like oh you know the earliest writings
on cave walls were just accounting
systems people keeping a ledger a
balance of who owes what and then i've
heard people who are like if your stick
is like storytelling it's like you know
the earliest things in cave walls or
stories passed down from genera they're
telling stories bedtime stories
essentially we're written on the walls
and now this guy's like saying something
else i actually believe yours yours
seems like to be honestly the most
beautiful i am talking about the written
line like words you're could be talking
about numbers and the other person could
be talking about pictures i'm talking
about like words but hey i'm i'm just
paraphrasing robert i'm just gonna use
that because no one [__] knows and so
i'm just gonna whatever it might like
i'm teaching a writing course right now
it's like did you know that the first
writing ever actually happened before
people ate it's like what that can't be
right that doesn't make sense yeah and
the first writing was about writing it's
like
by my course
i i'm just saying that's what i wrote
about
what do you think that like
i i wouldn't be surprised if basically
my daughter when she worked she never
went into an office she's using
something that's even more lightweight
than a phone it's a watch or it's a
contact lens to see her her information
that she works with people who she
doesn't know their identity and she they
don't know hers it's more like a game
it's like she's you know like
bb433 and she has like a five-star
rating and her out her rate is you know
x coins uh you know that's how she earns
her money and basically she works
whenever she wants and she like
basically every every morning can wake
up and see a list of available missions
to go contribute to like i can see that
being the future even though that sounds
like a video game today i think that the
jobs of the future feel like probably
will look more like games than than what
what we do today so there's this uh
i forget who said it but someone once
said um like what what i i'll look at
what rich silicon valley people do in
their free time and that's what a lot of
the world will do in 10 years and i
think this
slightly different chris dickson said
what the nerds in silicon valley do on
the weekends is what everybody will be
doing on their weekdays eventually
yeah and i think if i remember correctly
he might have been referring to like lsd
or psychedelic drug use i i think it was
like many hobbies it's like oh 3d
printing cryptocurrency like whatever
the
whatever the whatever like your engineer
friends are doing for fun on friday
saturday like outside of their job
that's the thing to bet on those are the
things that become things and i think
you could say the same for people who
are incredibly wealthy and let me give
you an example so we have this guy in
the podcast named mark uh why do you say
his last name laurie
mark laurie founded this company called
jet.com um he bought a basketball team
definitely a billionaire and when we
were doing the podcast it looked a
little funny like the way he was moving
his hands i couldn't exactly tell what
was going on and then afterwards he told
us that
he wasn't using his computer and he
basically was standing up and he had his
iphone on a big old tripod and he sent
us a picture of it and i tweeted out
about how i actually don't think that a
lot of people are going to be using
laptops i think that
um i've talked to a bunch of people i
think gary vaynerchuk's one of them uh
jack dorsey's another one mark lory is
another one and they run these huge
companies and they've created massive
amounts of wealth and mark lori said i
haven't touched a computer in years and
of course that is something that you
pretty much you kind of have to be
pretty wealthy in order to do that or
like a social media like influencer or
something like a jake paul type of
person
um but i do think that in 10 20 30 40
years this idea of having a laptop and a
computer i think is gonna be
we're not gonna do that we're going to
do it all from some type of
much very small handheld device
i i totally agree uh can i tell you a
fear story a random thing that happened
to me i uh i was in my backyard
yesterday or two days ago and i um i was
my we have this little like so we have a
pool and then there's like this little
hill that's kind of like um
it's like there's a bunch of greenery or
whatever and so it's like a little path
in the backyard you can just walk in a
circle and my daughter loves to do it so
i'm walking with her and we're walking
and i'm kind of on my phone and
she's walking like two steps ahead of me
and every three steps she just reaches
down to pick something up a flower a
rock a pebble it doesn't matter it's
dirt like she just likes to pick stuff
up
so she reaches down to pick up something
and i just hear this like this hiss i
just hear like
and i'm like
and i'm like uh i don't really and then
i hear like a rattle i just hear like
like and i'm like
i grab her i pull her towards me and i
look and right like six inches in front
of her
is a
enormous four-foot rattlesnake
and it is staring at her hissing at her
his little black tongue is like
flickering at my daughter
and i'm like i'm like oh holy [__] and
i'm like i'm like oh [__] and then she
goes oh [__] and then i'm like oh no
then i like i take her like six feet
away and i'm looking at it
and he stays still and i'm like
you know a different part of me wakes up
i think a part of me that you try
intentionally to wake up a lot which is
like kind of like your your like
survival instinct you're like primal
instinct you're like hillary clinton
this is real [__] like i know you like
to tap into that this is real [__] like
whether you're like all right i'm gonna
go box somebody and get hit and feel see
what that feels like i'm gonna do this
endurance race to see what it feels like
to almost die on this mountain
i don't do all that [__] right i look
for like you know where's the where's
the where's the couch and and so seeing
this tapped into that part of me and so
i'm like oh [__]
and so
um and so i'm looking at him he's
looking at me and i'm like okay so i get
my daughter out of there but i'm also
like
i need to get rid of the snake what am i
gonna do and so i call whoever i call
the i call the animal control server and
pest control or whatever animal control
and they're like oh no we don't do
snakes anymore we stopped at like you
know six months ago or something we only
do domestic animals i'm like okay [__]
who do i call i call the pest control
guy they're all booked up and they're
like oh we can get down to you on
wednesday i'm like dude this snake is
gonna move around between now and
wednesday and if we can't find him that
just means like i can't go in my
backyard at this point this is like a
four foot rattlesnake uh that is kissing
at me right now
and um did you know anyone with a gun
uh even if i knew someone with a gun i
wouldn't be like hey come shoot this
snake in the head like it just seems
like
no that seems like
that's about the way you give it to
snakes you you aim at their little tiny
you know head and you shoot it yeah
that's insane it's not that hard i mean
i've got friends that they uh yeah when
you find a snake you shoot it so okay so
that didn't come to mind for me but uh i
also live in a neighborhood where like
it's all just like old white rich people
and so like my neighbors are all like
80. so i'm like okay this is not gonna
this is not gonna go over super well
they're not gonna help me out
so then i call um so i call this little
museum i'm like hey you guys are a
museum uh nearby i'm like you
like wildlife museums they have like
real animals there i'm like you guys
want a snake i got a snake for you come
pick this up right um and they're like
actually there's a guy
this guy jim
who will do this for you and all the
other guys are quoting me like 800
thousand dollars to come remove this
snake and i'm like dude you could charge
any amount of money to remove a
rattlesnake and it's gonna basically get
accepted um and so i'm like all right
whatever and they're like this guy jim
can do it i'm gonna call him right now
they three-way him into the call he's
like hey oh you got a rattlesnake he
gets excited he's like i can get there
in 30 minutes i'm driving out of the
city
and i'm like okay like how much does
this cost he's like oh this is free i
love doing this
and so this guy comes over
i just i don't even know what the point
of the story is an amazing thing that
happened so this guy comes over
he's got this long beard looks like
dumbledore basically
and he's like
uh oh yeah he's like excited to see the
snake he tells first he tells me watch
the snake don't lose the snake so for 30
minutes i sit there 10 feet away from
the snake just in the heat it's 100
degrees outside i'm just sitting there
facing off with the snake i don't have
my phone i don't have anything
and i'm just staring at this thing the
whole time
that if you want to learn to meditate
find a rattlesnake and stare at it for
30 minutes unbelievable meditative state
so guy shows up he's got a tiny stick
with him basically like a little tiny
claw it's like and he goes up to the
snake no fear just starts like moving
stuff out of the way near the snake he's
like trying to get a good look at it
and um
he grabs the snake with his thing almost
loses it twice then he grabs he finally
gets it and he's like you got a bucket
and i'm like bro you should have said
this ahead of time like no i don't have
a bucket let me go find i go get an
amazon box
he's holding the snake in midair it's
like winding around like crazy hissing
like crazy we put in this box we tape it
up he's like can you just hold this tape
down i'm like bro
you don't understand how big of a [__]
i am like this you i know it's safe it's
in the box but like i don't want to
touch the box rattles i mean and that
will kill you right it'll ki it can kill
you i i was asking i was like dude you
just went up to no fear and he's like
not the fastest guy i was like you're
kind of slow like you're the snake was
moving way faster than you like you
weren't afraid he's like no i've done
this for years i love snakes he's like
i'm only afraid of like you know
mountain lions or something and he's
like um he's i was like but they do
attack he's like no he's like they
rattle as a defense mechanism they're
trying to get you to go away right like
a predator would not rattle at its prey
to scare it away it's more of a
defensive thing i'm like okay that makes
sense
and um anyway so he takes it away he
puts it in his car literally his
sister's in the car she's just been in
the car the whole time and i'm like dude
you're out here like
he's like yeah i was at her house i was
staying at her house when you called so
i just brought my sister over and the
sister's like oh god does the snake have
to come with us and he's like yeah of
course and he takes it to some mountain
and he lets it go and i'm like i'm like
you just do this for funny i love
animals and i go i go oh yeah i'm trying
to find small talk with this guy i don't
have anything in common with this person
i'm like my wife's a vegan that's the
best i can come up with and he goes
because oh i've been a vegan since 1956
or something like that what
i was like was it even a term then he
goes no there was no no term for vegan
but i just lived that way
and i was like wow
i just i don't know why i'm telling the
story i was just blown away by this
guy's like
authenticity and also
just the like quality of this person's
like beliefs and uh actions how
congruent they were and how selfless
they were like
we this is like kind of like a
money-minded podcast it's all about
opportunities and like taking advantage
of the situation and coming up with the
scheme
and this guy was like on the polar
opposite this guy was like
i love this thing i'm passionate about
this i do this for fun
um i live this lifestyle and i live it
not for the money or not for because
it's cool not because it's in vogue like
i was just kind of blown away by this
guy and i just needed to share that
story have you seen the documentary
shout out to you jim hale have you seen
the documentary of burt's bees
no there's a documentary about it it's
awesome i it's on netflix uh i don't
know if it is anymore but basically you
know burt's bees you know the the
chapstick shampoo i think the baby oh
yeah of course
you know how there's an old guy on it
that's bert right
no i didn't know that i thought it might
be like a kentucky fried chicken
situation
well i was a real guy too um you didn't
know that the colonel's a real guy i
knew he's real but they they made a
character right it's like oh yeah yeah
so bert was like the character but he's
a real guy he's alive still i think if
he died he must have been recently but
he's he's still around and
he uh would be he had a he had bees so
he was a beekeeper and he was kind of
this like mountain man type of guy who
lived uh maybe in new hampshire rhode
island somewhere up east where he lived
in in the woods kind of and he tended
bees and this entrepreneurial woman met
him and i was like hey i'm going to turn
your bees into or your honey into or
your hive i'm going to use this beeswax
to turn it into chapstick and it turned
into one thing and eventually she sold
it for like 200 million dollars and he
made like close to nothing he made very
little money but the company uh would
who bought it maybe nabisco one of these
huge conglomerates they ship them around
to japan to uh europe as like the
spokesperson because people just want to
see who byrd is and he's a real guy and
they were asking him in the documentary
who uh
like are you upset he goes no i don't
want that money i just want to go to bed
when the sun goes down and i want to
wake up when the sun comes up and i just
want to do whatever i want in between
and not talk to anyone i'm happy
and
he's a real character are you are you
looking them up now yeah i'm looking it
up okay i have some info here so company
starts 1991. bert owned a third of the
company quimby owned the other two
thirds
um
[Music]
he didn't get paid though
yeah so so bert's bees is now worth over
one billion
um
but he only got four million when she
sold it off for 173 million she gave him
4 million when he when she sold it for
173 million uh this the company still
pays him an undisclosed amount for his
likeness and name
um but you know he he sort of missed out
on on he would have been owed you know
much more um as far as as far as this
deal goes i don't know why it says he
owned one third and then only got four
million out of the 173 but whatever also
two things
unfortunately bert has bert passed away
at 80. um
like recently then yeah so that was
2015. so that that's pretty recently
and um
and also this guy looks identical almost
to the guy i was describing
so yeah
i'm glad you came up with this guy when
i was telling my story because they look
very very similar
it's great and uh anyway
i don't know where we're going with this
but
there is something to be said for these
people that are just happy without much
there's also this other show i've been
watching on hulu about these guys who
live on the land like there's this guy
who wears like rawhide like jacket and
pants and i've been watching on hulu and
he just lives he just he's like he lives
like a native american like in your in
your head like the like cowboys and
indians types where they just like
follow the food and they follow the
seasons and it does seem quite pleasant
so maybe this uh less than 40 hour work
week thing we're onto something here
well there's this like um quote which is
basically
uh i don't know who said this or i don't
know if anyone said this but basically
a lot of people want to learn from
podcasts like us like they want success
and success is getting what you want
and then happiness is wanting what you
get
and
practice both like don't just practice
the getting what you want because that's
a never-ending
you know you're on the mountain of more
and you'll never you'll never get to the
top of that mountain
and uh getting what you want or wanting
what you get is is you know that's
gratitude right and so you want to be
you want to master
both of those and if you could really
only pick one it would be wanting what
you get more so than getting what you
want
or as naval says uh i believe he says
desire is torture
or something like that
desires
buddhist philosophy
that uh when you want something you're
you're making a contract with yourself
to be unhappy until you get it which i
don't know if i actually believe that i
actually i actually don't believe that i
would say but
it is a kind of a buddhist principle
desire suffering
well maybe we should end there huh
leave them suffering for more all right
we're out of here
[Music]
travel never looking back